[Music]
a woman has been charged with abuse of a
corpse for a 2020 incident in which she
allegedly threw the ashes of her
boyfriend's mother
late mother i should say into a lake
hold on
how you handle ashes counts as abusive
that's [ __ ] yes you should be able
to dump that anywhere you want anywhere
wrong it didn't belong to her it
belonged to her boyfriend
so what had happened so what if your
wife and you broke up and then she took
like your uh mom's ashes all right cat
you're getting personal right now and
obviously i would fight my ex-wife yeah
yeah i'd obviously fight her you would
have to fight me show her how i'd hold
the knife though like
why would i but it'd scare her so
augustine gladney age 40 of fort worth
was arrested last month gladney gladney
oh she's too old to do this
she was arrested last month after she
reportedly admitted her actions to her
boyfriend ernest smith smith who was 38
told police back in june 2020 that he
returned home one night to find that the
urn containing his mother's cremated
remains was missing
smith told investigators he and glady
were dating at the time but were not on
good terms so allegedly
after some fight or something like that
what do you think the fight was about
awesome
but they were dating they were dating
this is casual but did she hate her mom
she hated his mom the mom was dead no
but she hated before i think it was just
petty i don't know oh it's like this is
what will hurt him emotionally how would
you know dude how would you know your
[ __ ]
the ashes are gone though yeah like
that's who's checking that check that
every time you get home okay maybe it
was the whole urn though
dude yeah maybe the urn is see-through
wow those that's new on the market
like a pimp's champagne cup wow
the whole urn was missing not that like
they couldn't see the content that's
where she [ __ ] up because she she
would have dusted it out and then she
put it back on a plastic bag on the
inside you know what i mean yeah just
you take the urn out and then the
plastic bag that has all the ashes is it
really like that a lot of the times the
dramatized version of plastic inside i
used to work at like a at a earth shop
why would you want to keep it why would
you want to keep
turkeys i thought when i said shop you
should have been like you're lying what
the [ __ ] an urn shop well it's like
something at agrabah
it was it was a it was a stand at the
mall
fast forward to may 2022 when smith told
authorities he overheard a phone
conversation between gladney and her
daughter she has a daughter
uh who was at their home at the time and
in that phone call gladney allegedly
told her daughter that she had thrown
the urn full of ashes into lake worth a
reservoir and recreation area in the
city
smith told police he was unable to reach
gladney until early midnight monday
night and it was apparently around that
time that she texted him admitting that
she had thrown his mother's ashes into
the water
that's [ __ ] up i find it is it [ __ ]
up though if she liked swimming there
yeah what if she what if that was her
that's a great logic for that or maybe
it's like you know she hates lake
gladney you know she hates it yeah
that's what that's why she said every
time we went fishing she would always
complain she [ __ ] hated that every
time she drove by that place she would
go out the window [ __ ] that leg
this [ __ ] gladness spectrum for abuse
of a corpse is very broad then
yeah because i thought she like i guess
it makes sense though because think
about it like uh if you were uh ernest
smith boyfriend right and same same kind
of personal situation somebody's taking
your mother's ashes and then [ __ ]
dumps it somewhere you're not thinking
like to you that's like that's my mother
so in that same way it's i guess it is
like the abuse of the remains crazy
because like usually when you think of
corpse like you're not thinking of ashes
and there's kind of a limited amount of
time to abuse a corpse that's your
limitations you just can't get to it
anymore i could find a few ways to abuse
some ashes yeah like how that just sucks
because damn that could
like how would you abuse smash what are
you gonna do this is the best part of
the video give us many examples i'll
[ __ ] make that [ __ ] into dough and
then melo
sexualized
our viewers
our viewer retention is spiking
the pottery scene of a ghost oh i can
make a pocket [ __ ] out of it and then
[ __ ] it maybe i don't want to add i
don't want to turn it into clay
maybe i want to just start sprinkling it
all over my body
to desecrate it on my ball sack like
it's baby powder oh [ __ ]
uh dude you got haunted though and whose
ashes do you want to desecrate on your
ball sack yeah enemies throw some names
anybody anybody i hate anybody enemies
ashes on your ball sack yeah cause i'm
this that's i mean why would you tell
somebody [ __ ] you if you if you hate
them
because that's a favor
you don't say [ __ ] you because you want
to
you just want to have sex with them
right that's what everyone says about
that's true i do want to have sex with
everyone one of my i hate you so [ __ ]
you i hate you so bad [ __ ] you two is
they think i'm hitting on them yeah
you've been hitting on them yup oh [ __ ]
damn anthony's got a big ass crush on me
yeah like dude this guy told me
city
tells me [ __ ] you every single day yeah
yeah just saying guys
but i don't know ash is i don't know
ashes are pretty gross let's just start
the word
that's true it's hard it seems pretty
easy if you wanted to like steal ashes
you just would take most of them yeah
fill the urn with ovaltine and then put
them in
what the hell is it
top it off with freaking dude we gotta
get cats and mobile teams it's like um
you wanna change your life no what is
that it's a great life change it's the
greatest breakfast vault hershey's
chocolate
it's like it starts as a powder and then
it's like you make chocolate milk oh
chocolate milk powder like the uh nestle
yeah yeah nicely yeah
is the best one though i never had it
it's like ness quick but well that's
because martin marketing in the 90s for
oval team was pretty aggressive yeah it
was yeah how come only chinese people
keep it alive now
if you go to a chinese restaurant they
have oval teams really yup oh i would
love to go to that restaurant
i would love to go to that restaurant
order nothing but ovaltine and leave
keep them coming they just freak them
out
three more staple like here you always
have like like uh sriracha at
restaurants oh yeah oh you're an
american staple my friend and i are here
to order some oval tea
keep bringing them all out until we one
of those passes the [ __ ] out
you guys want to be buried or burnt
i think i want to be um turn into ashes
and scattered at disneyland for no
reason at all yeah where the small world
god
the small world people really be doing
that a lot they do and that's why i want
to be part of it even though i don't
give a [ __ ] about disney well it's hard
because you can't go with the urn so i'm
gonna have to i'm gonna have to have
ashley steve in my pocket like this and
then while we're on the small world
right i'm gonna [ __ ] do it like she's
you
stupid
to do it like sort of dramatically
though like where everyone's definitely
going to see it and you definitely are
getting thrown out of disney
god
like right at the top of splash mountain
where like you throw it out but it all
just falls back on everything there's
just a photo everyone has ashes on their
little kids in front of like and you
went as a single rider so you don't know
the other four people
you are the front you have the front of
this
that's the [ __ ] move dude the rider
they came all the way from wisconsin
and they came for that picture dude gave
her that [ __ ] picture they were gonna
buy it and everything to make them shut
down space mountain because they have to
[ __ ] clean it all up humans
he didn't
you gotta go in the middle of like the
[ __ ] parade magic they turn the
lights on at space mountain you see ash
everywhere you're gonna ash elsa well
she's like waking up
yeah
have you seen when they um cremate monks
that are enlightened they bust out
their their remainders and then they
pull out they they pull out pearls
they say that they [ __ ] enlighten so
hard that after you you burn the [ __ ]
out of them
they turn into pearls dude you made me
do it
propaganda you know when you're at the
boardwalk and there's that one shop that
sells pearls and they put the pearls in
an oyster no matter which oyster you
choose like you'll always get a pearl
always get a purple that's blue
that's what it sounds like
whatever monkey burn you get pearls you
have pearls who's the monk that has the
pearl duty you know he's like he has
this [ __ ] wizard pearl planter and
then yeah he's like planning a pearl
he's like george yep here we go i need
some quick money i can just burn some
monks yeah dude monks are like like
right before they're about to get burnt
they're just like hey you got any extra
pearls like a swallow
yeah man
did that true did that one monk who
burned himself in that one famous photo
end up as a pearl no he just was on the
cover of rage against machine just a
bunch of pearls [ __ ]
he turned into pearls that's crazy
that's crazy everybody's just watching
it wait he's gonna turn to a pro hang on
wait for it
that's wild though burns like that was a
vietnamese monk oh yeah sounds like a
[ __ ]
pyramid scheme no that shit's crazy
that was a vietnamese monk yeah he
during the vietnam war that fool went
into the middle of the city poured
gasoline on himself and [ __ ] went
into lotus position and lit himself on
fire
and that [ __ ] was just he was just
chilling didn't scream
yeah he didn't scream nah
kicked it i think he was just like just
chanting or whatever his last words is
right at the end the whole man
[Laughter]
oh man
when you're in that town square you can
and you're really silent you could hear
him go no no
the legend the legend of no man
his spirit still lives on
he did it as a protest right yeah yeah
it's a protest
did it make anyone go like oh [ __ ]
that's kind of crazy
yeah the world well yeah the world but
not the leaders messaging like the
actual reason for why i did it but it
made everybody go holy shit's
[ __ ] can burn and not scream
that's awesome
dude don't you love how closely we are
now that would just throw cake at stuff
it's an iconic photo now that's a crazy
protest though
that's hardcore yeah don't ask me dude
i'm not gonna do it i already knew that
was coming you gotta you gotta get on
the button yeah
we're like talking about the weather and
he goes oh [ __ ] sorry
sorry that's [ __ ] barred every time
we haven't even gotten it so i know i
can feel when he's about to get up i
don't get the job done hey dude are the
best [ __ ] you're in the middle of a
story that everyone's listening to and
bart just goes like and you're like wait
what the [ __ ] okay no i gotta [ __ ]
try to finish my story okay
that's why we can't get guests because
every time the guests don't tell the
story he's like
he's like he like checked out the last
three minutes of the video and he just
clearly standing up in the middle of the
most interesting part of the story and
then you're like what the oh my god i'm
about to get cut off for no [ __ ]
reason
[Music]
[Music]
you